Sure,
George Gabriel on drugs says,
Jordan,
please help me.
I'm 99th percentile of openness and zero
with percentile and conscientiousness.
Yeah.
Well,
how old are you?
That's the first thing.
If you're,
if you're young,
that's um,
because younger people are less
conscientious.
So that's one thing to keep in mind if
you're very open like that,
you need to be doing something creative,
but you're going to have to learn how to
discipline yourself.
There's just no way around it.
And I would say go do the future
authoring program.
That's a good start and you'll have to
learn how to schedule your time then and
how to get up at the same time everyday
and it's going to be a real struggle,
but you know,
you,
you can do it.
I've had students who were very high in
openness and low in conscientiousness,
his graduate students and they
disciplined themselves.
You need to find something that you're
really interested in that you're willing
to pursue and then you have to hit it
hard.
Um,
so that's what I would say,
but do the future authoring program and
get yourself a plan and start to
implement it.
And every time you fall astray then get
back at it.
And you know,
you may have to build up your
conscientiousness over a number of years
and,
but it's worth doing.
So.